how can I make sure that I'm using the
right words you can't
yeah it's very simple question
the thing is with enough exposure
with enough listening and reading and
speaking your brain will gradually
develop better and better habits in time
it's a bit like AI you know the
automatic translation or automatic you
know transcriptions or translations has
improved so much because of the vast
quantity of data that has become
available to these engines that then
make the system better it's the same
with language your brain is absorbing
all this data it's absorbing the
language spoken by native speakers
sometimes incorrectly and then the brain
will remove that because it doesn't come
up that often but but it's develops
better and better habits over time